thank you alejandro yes we are hinted
with the eight-time national champion
irina crush irena this match almost
feels like a clash of generations you
are the established grand master she's
the upper uh coming how did you approach
this match
yeah that's true i mean she's just 14
years old i think right so i mean yeah
some people at some point you're
starting to
to play people that could uh could like
be your daughters
funny to say that but you know i'm kind
of used to being the youngest player
i've just been you know playing for so
long but
yeah i mean how do i approach this match
um you know just this normal way looking
at her games you know getting sort of a
profile of what she plays which what
kind of position she likes and then
figuring out my strategy and i think you
know my idea for this game worked worked
pretty well it definitely felt like the
strategy especially in the opening
played quite well let's look at the game
where do you feel like you're taking
over
yeah well um she she didn't play the
move age six in the opening which um
it's kind of important
um now
yeah like like let's say we go back a
couple of moves um before let's say
actually right in the beginning
somewhere in the beginning like the move
h6 like she can probably include at
various points but like it really should
come kind of early right because at some
point you might not have it anymore
because of bishop f6 so yeah she should
just be playing the same position with
the move h6 um because that gives her
ideas of g5 now
since she played without this move she
didn't really have this h6 g5 id anymore
and so she went for knight c4 which i
thought was interesting um let me go a
few moves further
yeah here we are
um so c5 yeah you have to take with the
knight and now knight c4 is pretty much
what black has to do this and try to
gain the tempo on the bishop on
g5 and it was kind of a big moment for
me because at first i was even thinking
like maybe i should castle and i had to
decide between bishop f4 and bishop h4
but ultimately i just went for bishop h4
i stayed on this diagonal
um
decided not to give up the bishop so
easily
and yeah honestly i just liked my
position here like i grabbed this pawn
and
i was surprised that she never
she didn't want to take up right i
didn't want to take it i mean of course
i liked my position but i certainly was
expecting black to take this pawn at
some point
and here i just have like so many
choices right i went for queen a6 which
just seems like very
simple and playing for c4
um here i'll show you one interesting
tactical point okay so it says double
question mark knight d2 yeah let's keep
going
um knight c4 and here i was looking at
the move um knight f3
and i think you know white is definitely
in a position where they can start
thinking about winning a piece
and the reason i didn't go for this one
uh is because of queen b2 which i think
is the only move and she kind of
annoyingly attacks my rook on c1 so i
cannot capture the knight on d7 so i
didn't really see a way
um past this is queen on b2 is pretty
untouchable
so i'm not sure like in what way knight
d2 was like a total blunder because i
didn't see
like how i was winning a piece but what
i went for you know was still pretty
nice for white
your
extra pawn up and
well when
we got when we saw a position where your
knight was on d6 like right here we just
like said whoop
that's it irina's just gonna uh you know
reel home the victory and you probably
felt that way that you were doing a very
good job for a very long time
and then you gave her a chance by giving
up your beautiful knight
yeah so knight c8 right um yeah of
course i was very happy to get in like
f3 and e4 then i saw she could like try
to trade the night
you're killing her bishop by putting the
pawn yeah what did i do i went knight c4
i had this yeah funny i i had all these
squares i could go with my knight but
then i finally realized oh you know e5
is an interesting square to try to get
to
um
and looks really really promising and
she went back i think to b6 right
and put her bishop on age five yeah and
somehow you know it's not so terrible on
h5 because she has ideas of like let's
say king h8 or king h7 and f6 bishop f7
um so this position wasn't as easy for
me as like i was hoping it would be i i
was deciding here between h3 and h4
i went for h3 and of course putting the
king on h2 was one of the best things i
did in this game as it turned out you
know because it was very safe there
right
yeah and how did those nights come off
yes
oh they're yeah rook d6 yeah
so you're doing everything that you want
to do yeah
everything was going really well and
then i don't know where should i have
put my knight well
uh i could imagine that you that knight
d3 might have been a decent start
because you could get to play knight f4
yeah
yeah she'll go like queen c2 i guess i
see this is what you were saying yeah i
mean i i didn't think it like it was
that clear since her bishop returns to
f7 and she's got like of course i'm
better but yeah maybe i have a five yeah
i'm taking knight f but you know i never
wanted her knight to go to c4 e3 and f1
that was um you know another thing that
yeah it's interesting but the nitrate
was that bad you know
of course
i could feel that my advantage was you
know a lot of it gone yes
uh here the remarkably i think christian
helped me out here i think you were
pointing out the computer was saying
bishop c6 and it's not that bad well
even after queen to d4 i think rook to
b4 i think was played and then no queen
to a3 okay bishop to c6 this was still
fine
but i do think that queen d7 bishop b7
was just the wrong way because now you
get to open up the position i think now
you guys yeah this i was happy about
once i got my rook to d7 then finally
yeah you finally got your grippers back
on and you went on to win the game how
does it feel uh
behind the chess board once more are you
getting the feeling of the pieces yeah i
think so i think this was a you know a
pretty good game to get into it because
we did kind of get lower on time so
there was that kind of tension at the
end i mean i managed my time okay
but you know when you get down to two or
three minutes um you know you have to be
kind of alert right and
not you're not cruising anymore when
you've got that little time so you're
you know i think it's good to have a
little bit of that tension in your first
game and fabiano was mentioning
something very interesting uh this time
control that you don't get a second time
control he said he probably played this
type of event 10 years ago when was the
last time you remember playing this type
of yeah this there was a point when this
kind of time control was pretty popular
and i definitely remember playing it i
guess even in maybe in like i don't know
olympiads or world championships i but
um they've moved away from this and it's
true i have not played just pure game 90
in like a really long time
do you feel any extra pressure with
those minutes sticking down
yeah i mean i want my opponents to have
less time than me so it's a it's a
little bit less pressure like that way i
mean that's definitely going to be my
goal i think time management is really
important with this time control i mean
i don't think i'm the best you know
having like 30 seconds on the clock so
like i will definitely make an effort to
have more time than my opponents irina
thank you very much for joining us and
we'll see you tomorrow thank you guys
thank you thank you irina and thank you